puni pour avoir enquêté ça n'arrive pas
qu'aux journalistes australiens edwards
père un reporter français de l'émission
cash investigations révèlent en 2013
avec l'aide de deux lanceurs d'alert
antoine deltour et raphaël allaitent les
secrets des basions fiscal de
l'entreprise luxembourgeoise pwc dont
ils sont tous les deux salariés
cette enquête avait permis de mettre en
évidence un système d'accords fiscaux
négociés directement par les filiales
luxembourgeoises des grands cabinets
d'audit avec le fisc luxembourgeois pour
permettre à 340 multinationale de
déroger au régime fiscal de droit commun
parmi elles ikea apple ou bien encore
pepsi c'est la fameuse affaire luc
slicks qui avait fait grand bruit trop
de bruit au goût du cabinet d'audit qui
fait alors saisir le matériel
informatique de raphaël allaitent à son
domicile une saisie obtenue grâce à la
signature d'une ordonnance du juge des
référés de metz en 2014 pwc ordonne des
mesures d'instruction à l'encontre de
son salariés résidant en france contre
lequel elle nourrissait des soupçons en
désignant un huissier chargé de se
rendre à son domicile et d'établir la
liste des documents relatifs à
l'activité de l'entreprise qu'il
détenait une ordonnance qui va à
l'encontre de la justice pour edouard
perrin qui engage alors une procédure
afin de la faire annuler objectif est
dénoncé une violation manifeste par pwc
du secret des sources
le procureur de la république donne
raison à edouard perrin en décembre 2017
mais la puissance et les arguments de
pwc fait changer d'avis le tgi de metz
quelques mois plus tard en première
instance la justice déboute le
journaliste et le condamne même à payer
une amende de 3000 euros
edouard perrin ne justifie pas l'intérêt
qu'il a à agir à titre personnel
trois ans après la mise en oeuvre de
l'ordonance querellés alors qu'il est
hier à celle ci il ne justifie pas non
plus d'une quelconque habilitation à
défendre l'intérêt général ou l'intérêt
général des journalistes
et ce faisant n'apporte aucun élément de
preuve de la recevabilité de son action
soutenue par le snj edouard perrin a
fait appel cette décision
est-ce qu on peut le dire car si on suit
la logique du tribunal comme le dit ce
communiqué du snj
une entreprise peut donc accéder à la
correspondance du salarié y compris
celle qu'il entretient avec un
journaliste
une entreprise peut aussi indirectement
faire taire un journaliste faire primer
le secret des affaires sur le secret des
sources et ainsi empêcher la diffusion
de documents même si leurs publications
va clairement dans le sens de l'intérêt
général
c'est là tout le couac de ce feuilleton
judiciaire qui remettent en cause d'une
fois plus le travail des lanceurs
d'alerté
l'audience qui s'est tenue ce mardi
devant la cour d'appel de metz doit nous
dire si la vérité triomphera
réponse le 25 mars prochain date du
délibéré